Gigi Gonzalez he's gonna get the ball to
start the second half not planned not
scripted he was expected to start
tomorrow in the Saturday Affair but
today will be his day he found out Jeff
yesterday after some testing came in
from the covet faces are now loaded in
the first inning couple of free passes
set in the table for this Dodger offense
is an explosive situation and Bellinger
is a pretty good candidate to get it
done 1-0 pitch to Ballinger
is in the right center a base hit bits
is going to score and coming around
third as Turner he is in two nothing
Dodgers Cody Bellinger breaks the ice
with a two-run base hit Cody gets jammed
but it's effective hit it hard sometimes
you line out hit a little softer but
hard enough to get over the infield
eyes and that's what he gets on this
full swing Jam shot you take the RBIs
any way you get them alinger with two
RBIs 19 on the year All-Star Chris
Taylor one out and Runners at the
corners chance to add on for more 1-1
and Tanner hits a ball high and deep
till that fail way back and gone a
three-run shot for ct3 and the Dodgers
have opened it up in the top of the
first inning what a shot by Taylor a
hanging backup slider hits Justin Turner
Gonzalez makes an adjustment on the
slider to Taylor but it's just hanging
and it's in the middle of the plate and
CT does not miss it
squares it up and he knew it was gone
but even his jogging speed he's pretty
fast
sounds good and if it's in the air and
sounds good it cores it's probably
leaving the park it is a deep ballpark
Julio taking his 19th start of that
record 11-3 very impressive and we'll
see what he decides to go with the
majority of the time that against the
Rockies he has been successful with his
fastball against them this year but that
has been the Achilles heel against the
rest of the league
in my opinion the change up has been
good and it's been hot lately that could
end up being a very successful pitch
today for him yeah the one two
there's a ground ball to short bucks
handles one down Brendan Rodgers
and Rogers out on strikes two down first
strike out of the game for Urus second
out of the first CJ Crone Throne batting
in the fifth spot one two to Crow that's
belted toward the middle great play by
Taylor ah Chris Taylor positioned
perfectly
makes the outstanding play to end the
unit two on and Will Smith up Will Smith
hits it towards right center field
Blackman On The Run reaches up and makes
the catch catchling on to the warning
track Charlie Blackman takes away extra
bases and the Dodgers don't score 5-0 La
here in the second Bellinger one for one
2-0 swing in a shot reaching play by
Brendan Rodgers to spear the looping
liner along the right side Rocky's with
a couple of fine defensive plays in this
one in Bellinger's out number one they
got a big crowd on hand and you want to
give the hometown gang a little
something it's been all on the defensive
side so far Brendan with the backhanded
extension and then somehow kept his
balance to make the play great
opportunity against
urea searing the third one out and CJ
Crone coming up but this is where the
Rockies need one of those big swings
here certainly take the Grand Slam I'm
not going to dismiss it and say no I
wouldn't take it
is
left field Jack Houston
CJ Brown with another grand slam all of
a sudden it's a 5-4 ball game bro making
it look easy and he knew it immediately
there you go boys take my back two men
out Will Smith coming up first and third
two guys Smith to right field and deep
Blackman going back it's going to be off
the wall Khalil comes in to score Ben
it's around third on his way he'll be in
and Smith that second with a two out two
run double it's seven to four Reeves and
Bets set the table and the last guy to
the table got to eat and that was Will
Smith this Fly ball hit a little bit
lower than muncie's hit about just as
hard and this one makes the wall and
scores two the second and third one out
and beds is two for three
cool first ball swinging drives it to
Center
Pollock tagging he's coming to the plate
throw comes into third Bets with a run
driven in on a sacrifice fly and it's
eight to four take that Smith looking
for one to drive oh on the will and he
knocks this one in the left Center fan a
base hit Lux will score Here Comes
Muncie two more in it is 10-4 two more
runs batted in for Will Smith four in
the game 36 on the season sometimes
you're reading hitter swings foul balls
sometimes you should read their posture
after you throw them a breaking ball
when will jumped out of the way it just
immediately flashed in my head he is
sitting on a fastball jumped out of the
way of the small slider and he gets a
fastball down the middle and he is all
over it big night in the cleanup spot
for Will Smith as he has done just that
in the fourth and fifth Innings Will
Smith the batter here in the top of the
eighth and Ben Bowden will do the
pitching for the Rockies out of the pen
Andy got it so a good start for Ben
Bowden fourth time that Ben has been on
the active roster for the Rockies and
climbed the ladder with the strikeout
just shy of the letter was that fastball
two and two
[Music]
[Applause]
it's for Ben Bowden we've talked about
when Ben has struggled the command and
and the control along with it but
fastball command is something Bud Black
preaches and Ben Bowden has come out
with that tonight that another pitch
up around the letters and It's just
tough when it comes in at that velocity
with a little movement too to to get on
top of it and drive it tailor aboard
with two outs and AJ Pollock will get a
chance to hit 2-2 to Pollock swing and a
miss he got him on a foul tip strike
three
Ben Bowden ends up striking out the side
we go to the bottom of the eighth one
out bottom of the ninth and O2 the count
surefie facing Trevor's story here
third Turner goes to Second for one
around the horn game over Dodgers take
game one by a 10-4 score when they're
57th of the year